timer was the stand-in for Judy so timer
would come in like with me
come here come in for a tell and just be
perfect every single time and then right
before the cameras got set up in the
lights they would say okay bring judy in
and pour timer we just like look around
and get swept up swept off the stage
she'd be like what I can run circles
around this [ __ ] wait a second sighing
Bishop as good as it gets
that was a script by mark Andrus and Jim
Brooks that was you know off the charts
great still to this day one of the best
scripts I ever read it was called old
friends and Jim kept going no man I
don't like the name the names terrible
and I was like Jim
trust me the names great he was right I
was wrong as good as it gets was was a
line that Jack utters in the movie I was
shooting another film up in San
Francisco and Jim Brooks and Francine
Maslow actually came up to visit me you
know I read for him and then I kept just
trying to pretend that Jack Nicholson
was not in the movie because I was too
it's too big of a fan it's too crazy to
think that I was getting close to doing
a movie with Jack much less when I get
the call saying okay Greg we're gonna
have you go over to Jack's house tonight
and just you know read through some
scenes oh really that's it huh just go
to Jack's house and read through some
scenes I was terrifying her everything
looks distorted and everything inside we
shot the movie for a very very long time
and I felt like Jim who's such a
brilliant artist was just searching for
these the sound he knew it
so specifically and I was a huge fan of
you know broadcast news and you know
terms of endearment he so didn't
disappoint me in being the artist that I
knew he was and was so great at bringing
you know all of us that whole cast
including Helen whose off-the-charts
great together and knowing what we were
all there to do he had a he had a thing
he was looking for and the more we shot
the more it seemed to coalesce Frank
Navasky you've got mail
well that was with Nora Ephron the
wonderful talented Nora I cannot say
enough about that woman incredible
writer and talent and human being you
know it was kind of based on a writer
from The Observer in New York that she
knew you know the guy I was playing in
it was you know he was a little bit of a
nerd and it was great fun to play
because he was you know he's definitely
the guy that doesn't get the girl when
you got Tom in the movie and Meg
you don't love me
me either you don't love me I really
liked Frank he was a lovely little
character and I felt like I was just
gonna make a observation about something
that would have been funny and amusing
but I lost it
Oh hold on that's giving me time to
think
no no tulle around with that for a
second I
it still looks off to me I think the
microphone I worked with Michael Palin
the great Michael Palin
one of my my favorite actors dating back
to Monty Python days was also in people
don't realize this because he ended up
getting cut out of the movie tragically
because we had great stuff Michael has
had a really funny role in the movie and
it just it just didn't pan out and in
the final story but one of the great
joys of the movie is a bunch of stuff
that ended up on the cutting room floor
for me it was my work with with Michael
David Larrabee Sabrina was the first
movie that I ever got cast in I was
basically looking at clips of Jerry
Springer and Geraldo ho on a show called
talk soup and Sydney [ __ ] who was an
amazing director producer and actor damn
he's good got ahold of a tape from that
show and brought me into his office to
talk to him about the role I just
thought he wanted me to you know come in
there because he couldn't believe
anybody else was from a smaller town
than him in Indiana he was engaging and
interesting and got me relaxed then told
me I'd be playing Harrison Ford's
brother which kind of killed the
relaxation part of it I'm not ready to
make this kind of commitment I say she
must have asked for an actual wedding
date I don't know what came over me she
was healing children I was in a tuxedo
I'm not in any position to take care of
a wife Elizabeth is a doctor and a
millionaire David she won't be a burden
we read through a few scenes and he
me comeback and eventually I got a call
from my agent asking me if I was sitting
down I believe I was but he told me that
I was gonna play this play this role and
it was a tricky movie to do because
obviously it's a beloved remake William
Holden is a you know and certainly a
beloved actor my mom was a big fan and
so I was taking on his role and I kind
of felt like this isn't real the set was
very you know way crazy over the top
with always that seemed to be a thousand
extras and everybody's sipping champagne
both when we were rolling and not
rolling it was all quite lovely and it
was a hell of a way to start
autofocus Bob Crane Bob Crane was a TV
star from the from the 70s on a show
that I loved called Hogan's Heroes and
it turns out Bob had a bit of a what we
think is a sexual addiction Willem Dafoe
plays John Carpenter the man who was
suspected ultimately of bludgeoning Bob
to death with a camera tripod and it's
it's definitely a tragic story but it
was an interesting especially in the
current environment and all of its you
know excesses Welwyn days venom there's
got to be surprise inspection I don't
know about you guys there's gonna be an
inspection
I got things to hide I got things gonna
be insulation
it's kind of an outrageous movie but one
of my favorite films my kids are never
gonna watch it but uh I actually really
think that the movie is profound and
there's no doubt that it captures the
essence of a struggle that this guy
really had Richard Hoover Little Miss
Sunshine yeah that was a movie sorry
that was a good movie huh no no but I
like that movie I'm trying to think of
what I do want to talk about let's not
skip through this it's a hit for God's
sake so let's keep it on for a second
I'm waxing poetic on a movie that was
seen by about a hundred thousand people
we finally are a little miss sunshine
you want to move on for God's sakes I
don't got that many of these anyway what
you asked about that movie was a gift
Jonathan Dayton and Valerie Faris had
not directed a movie before they've done
a lot of commercial work this movie had
been out there in fact a friend of mine
David friendly first showed me the
script and I was like yeah seems cool
let's do it and it just couldn't get its
funding together nobody thought that was
a movie to be made and so a year went by
two years went by I was a little in
touch with John and Valerie and they
were like yeah we really want to make
the movie cuz this girl Abigail
breslin's getting older so Abigail was
now I think nine nine and a half when we
finally shot it and she was just so
right for that role for obvious reasons
the producer Mark turtlemom I think
originally I think he just wrote a check
for seven million dollars and that's how
we ended up making the movie but the
script was great it was great you know
much better than I realized
honestly I read Little Miss Sunshine I
was like yeah it's it's it's good I
seemed it seemed good seemed seemed
smart and then as we got closer to it
and I kind of like
you know kind of dove into again I was
like oh my gosh this thing is so great
like every beat every nuance the
characters everything and I just I knew
it was it first blush good but I didn't
know it was exceptional but it really
was and I thought you know once we got
together we really had something because
John and Val wanted to do a thing which
no one seems to do anymore and show
business called rehearsal so we all got
together in this strange space over in I
don't know a near Culver City Steve and
Tony and Alan the whole gang we did
weird stuff as weird actory stuff we had
little Diaries and we'd write what the
other characters thought about us we
play dodgeball together
I drove us in that yellow van to the
valley to go bowling and about killed us
for the first time when we made the
movie I almost killed this another 30 or
40 times it was the most dangerous movie
ever made
because we did all our own driving there
was no we didn't have stunt people they
nobody could afford that
[Music]
if you saw a red or a yellow van
screaming down the freeway at about
sixty miles an hour with a bunch of
cameras in it it was probably us
Rigsby bear detective Vogel a very kind
of imaginative script and I had no idea
that how that movie was in turnout and
it's a little Jim it's a great little
film that captures the spirit of
imagination and creativity what's that
on your shirt it's brings me of course
detective Vogel is a closeted actor and
he he actually is helping James who's a
kidnap victim who's kind of adapting to
his new freedom in in making a movie he
wants to make a movie called Briggs be
fair based upon the movie that is
psychotic captor played by Mark Hamill
actually showed him repeatedly when he
was a child I hope this is all making
perfect sense to you at home who haven't
seen the movie because I can't explain
it any clearer than that
but it's a great movie that's all I can
tell you dr. David Ravell
nurse betty was a wonderful script in
fact they won the Golden Globe I believe
that year I was playing a soap opera
star opposite Renee Zellweger she has a
develops a strange kind of otherworldly
crush on me and believes that I'm a real
doctor Chris Rock Morgan Freeman also in
the movie directed by Neil the beauty
it's a really really good movie one of
my favorites and I remember them really
having trouble with it I remember
watching an early cut of nurse Betty and
saying well that sucks
because it just didn't work and they
finally they found it though and they
through a lot of work and effort I think
they and it shows you what can happen
editorial Ian I also remember because I
worked again with Renee not too long ago
and we were recounting the fact that I
kind of lost it it's the only movie I've
ever done in my life where I literally
just lost
we had a scene where she's in a little
nurse's outfit and we're in a diner and
I'm dr. David Ravell and I say something
and we're on a soap opera now there's
always a chance David what about
tomorrow and the next day and the next
day we just lost it we lost it
completely I've never laughed so hard
and it was funny at first and this the
time went by you know you're kind of
looking at the crew kind of people are
looking around and ranae and I are
recognizing that it's kind of past it's
expiration point now and we really just
need to shoot the goddamn thing I ended
up with a c-stand with a tennis ball on
it representing Renee Zellweger saying
cherry your eyes look like moonbeams or
whatever the hell the line was and she
did the same for me that's the only way
we could complete the scene we're both
mortified by it to this day but hey man
show business bill Shepherd and house of
cards great thrilled to do it in in the
sense that it's just an iconic show and
it deserves to have a final season which
was close - not happening credit to
Robin Wright for kind of keeping the
train on the tracks also the writers
being able to retool this and I think
MRC and Netflix you know for taking care
of the crew I mean this is an incredible
crew you watch that show and yeah the
actors are front and center but there
are so many professionals behind the
camera making it look seamless and
incredible and it was great fun to do it
I've always been a fan of Diane lanes
the idea that she would be my sister and
partner and evil seem great we do have
kind of a Bob Hope Doris Day thing going
on so to actually flip that upside down
and make us formidable enemies trying to
destroy Claire's life was I think pretty
effective was great fun to do I mean
they really know how to create chaos
even more than and what's happening in
Washington on house of cards it's pretty
good stuff you know it's a hard question
you know what you look for in a
character because I'm not looking for
anything when I read a script it kind of
needs to find me I feel like it's like I
never thought of a guy capable of doing
that or having that agenda this is all
the writers are great at this but I find
that it usually is not my search to find
something I its reading something and
being surprised this time goes on it
gets harder and harder I think to get
surprised but if they're still out there
and it's still it's still as exciting as
hell when you when you find something
where you're like oh that would be fun
[Music]